bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78 dans le
cadre des élections municipales débat
aujourd'hui consacré à villepreux et
débat que vous pouvez suivre également
sur l'antenne de radio sensations 98.4
dans les yvelines cinq listes déclarées
dans cette commune de villepreux en date
du 23 février leurs cinq représentantes
accepté de venir en plateau d'on joueur
avoue 5
je vous précise et vous le savez déjà
que ce temps de parole sera chronométrée
afin de veiller au mieux à l'égalité
entre vous nous allons faire un premier
tour de table pourquoi vous présentez à
villepreux pourquoi vouloir revêtir
l'écharpé tricolore nous allons débuter
avec curro ce golgotha
c'est le tirage au sort qu'il en a qui
en a décidé ainsi et puis pour la
conclusion nous irons ensuite en sens
inverse
en fin d'émission dans une heure cros
golgoht lab pourquoi cette candidature
je précise que votre liste sera sans
étiquette même si vous avez une
sensibilité plutôt à droite est à
l'origine vous souhaitiez interrogé
interpeller les candidats sur leurs
propositions et finalement vous avez
décidé de vous présenter exactement ça
je vous remercie de nous inviter pour
cet exercice démocratique qui a permis
depuis un mois un mois et demi de
changer beaucoup de choses sur la ville
qui a permis d'avancer et de se
repositionner sur beaucoup de certitudes
et les projets ont changé je suis
médecin et chirurgien orl j'habite vitro
depuis 18 ans chez 3 enfants qui ont été
scolarisés sur la ville et qui continue
à faire des études supérieures ils vont
aller au collège
il chante au lycée je me permets de vous
faire une remarque une citation d'un
grand homme qui est notre parrain à tous
le père de la nation
il ya qu une réussite qu'à partir de la
vérité c'est général de gaulle
donc cet exercice cette discussion en
direct avec les candidats c'est très
important et se permet de savoir et de
connaître les positions de chacun je
veux que villepin évolué je veux que
vivre eux augmentent au niveau du
standing
je veux que la taxation diminue je
souhaite améliorer la ville et donc j'ai
réussi à convaincre des gens de la
société civile
j'ai aucun élu dans mon équipe engagée
dans la vie associative de me suivre et
de faire un projet très élaborés
travailler des centaines d'heures avec
des thèmes bien définis très
succinctement et bien expliquer qu'on
soumet aux vip rosien conçoit et vu ou
pas je pense toutefois que je viens de
dire ça nous a permis d'avancer déjà
beaucoup pour la vie
sylvie et ce moment tel élu en 2008 dans
la majorité de stéphane mirambeau vous
revendiquez plutôt une sensibilité à
droite mais là aussi une liste que vous
dites sans étiquette sans investiture du
soutien de deux parties des anciens
membres de la majorité vous ont rejoint
oui bonjour bonjour à tous donc je suis
élu depuis donc 12 ans et donc onze ans
et demi dans la majorité municipale donc
une expérience très riche depuis 2008
c'est vrai qu'on a fait énormément de
choses le bilan est positif sur sur ces
demandes a donc donc c'est des points
extrêmement portant sur l'ensemble des
sujets je vais pas revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé cet été ce n'est pas
absolument pas utile ce qui est certain
c'est qu'à partir du 11 septembre
beaucoup de vie de produit un sens
plusieurs centaines m'ont sollicité et
parce que ce n'était pas prévu au
programme même si je suis prête
c'était pas prévu et les bills problème
vraiment sollicité pour que j'aille sur
cette campagne que je puisse me
présenter
donc j'ai bien réfléchi et donc mes
motivations elles sont de plus en plus
forte puisque du coup j'ai repris ma
liberté
c'est une liberté qui est extrêmement
extrêmement importante et des choses qui
m'a dit moi je la reprends procès
c'est vraiment pour moi fondamental et
donc du coup on s'est lancé dans la
campagne depuis le mois de début
décembre et donc
et donc voilà c'est parti jean baptiste
à monique délégué départemental du modem
à la tête d'une liste dite pluriel on
retrouve une dizaine d'élus sortants
également à vos côtés oui tout à fait
bonjour wilfried merci à vous pour
l'organisation de ce débat et à télé 78
j'espère que ce sera l'occasion pour
nous d'éclairer certaines positions tout
à fait moi je suis candidat depuis le
mois d'octobre avec la liste villepreux
naturellement qui est une liste qui
rassemble à la fois des élus sortants de
la majorité mais également de la
position ce qui montre aussi notre
capacité à rassembler au delà des
clivages partisans vous avez évoqué ma
responsabilité de référent du modem
départemental je ne mange pas je ne m'en
cache pas je ne me cache pas d'avoir une
appartenance politique dans cette
élection je pense que c'est essentiel de
le dire nous avons effectivement des
soutien de plusieurs partis politiques
du nombre de neuf qui sont à la fois des
soutiens de partis politiques qui
soutiennent la majorité gouvernementale
actuelle mais également de l'opposition
avec une connotation aussi très
environnementale
aujourd'hui cette liste elle est
représentative de la commune elle
représente l'ensemble des générations
l'ensemble des quartiers avec je le
disais de l'expérience incarné par des
élus six anciens 7 juin sont aujourd'hui
dans mon équipe
et puis des nouveaux visages des
nouveaux venus qui arrive avec la
volonté aussi d'apporter un nouveau
souffle à villepreux parce que c'est
dans cette démarche là qu'on souhaitons
nous inscrire vous le verrez au cours de
ce débat moi je suis pas là pour renier
tout ce qui a été fait auparavant ce qui
a été fait et bien fait je le dirai je
le reconnaîtrai sans problème je pense
qu'on excusez l'expression mais en crève
en politique justement de pas avoir
cette honnêteté intellectuelle de dire
ce qui a été bien fait en revanche nous
sommes à notre sens à la fin d'un
système
à la fin d'un modèle qui n'est plus
viable et plus durable pour villepreux
et c'est pour ça que j'aurais l'occasion
aujourd'hui d'expliquer quel est le
nouveau souffle que nous souhaitons
impulser sur la commune ont également
présents pour débattre sur ce plateau
concernant la ville de villepreux
stéphane mirambeau vous êtes le maire
sortant vous aviez annoncé un temps ne
pas vouloir vous représentez et
finalement aujourd'hui vous faites
campagne avec une liste sans étiquette
même si vous restez adhérents de la
république en marche je suis encore déjà
je vous remercie pour votre pour votre
accueil donc pourquoi
candidature sur ville peut simplement
pour au plus haut pour plusieurs raisons
la première raison quand on quand j'ai
créé quand j'ai pensé quand j'ai imaginé
le projet pour villepreux en 2007 je me
suis rendu compte très très vite quand
j'ai été élue que le temps administratif
était particulièrement long et le projet
que j'avais envisagé pour cette ville je
me rends compte que il faut encore un
mandat pour pouvoir vraiment le mener à
bien dans sa séance est vraiment le
premier le premier objectif la première
raison de mon engagement
la deuxième raison c'est que je peux
aujourd'hui présenté un bilan de douze
années de gestion leur certains disent
qu'un bilan
ce n'est pas tous certes mais c'est
souvent ceux qui n'ont aucun bilan
d'ailleurs qu'il le dise un bilan c'est
la garantie pour les électeurs que je
vais pouvoir faire et que je veux vous
voir affronter en toute circonstance les
différents enjeux qui s'ouvre à vil prix
pour ces prochaines années
il faut bien rappeler également qu'on a
besoin d'un maire expérimenté en
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier les
communes sont en difficulté des
dotations versées aux collectivités sont
encore une réalité
la hausse de la péréquation et 2 et
demain nous avons une crainte évidente
alors que nous vivons essentiellement de
cela de la suppression et des
conséquences de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation également nous
pourrons parler des montées en puissance
de l'intercommunalité et demain ce sera
un sujet nous n'aurons pas le temps ce
moment d'en parler il y aura le sujet
défi des fusions de communes qui
arrivera également sur la table
la dernière raison c'est que moi je me
rends compte aussi parce que ça fait 12
ans que je suis à la tête de la ville
que la situation de villepreux reste
encore extrêmement fragile et que toute
décision irresponsable comme certaine
que je peux dire pourrait mettre à mal
et rendre maîtres ville près dans une
situation extrêmement dangereuse
voici pourquoi pour ces quatre raisons
je suis candidat une nouvelle fois pour
briguer mon troisième et dernier mandat
avant de passer la parole à dernières
candidates petit rappel juste technique
si vous pouviez vous redresser un tout
petit peu monsieur mirambeau voilà comme
ça on verra mieux à l'image par rapport
au cadre des caméras voilà pour la
petite précision valérie ben également
candidate vous souhaitez mais une ligne
mené une liste pardon sans étiquette
mais que vous dites citoyennes et et
plurielle à vos côtés des élus du
conseil municipal qui siégeait dans la
majorité également il vous est adhérente
sauf erreur de ma part et la république
en marche donc oui mais écoutez je suis
fier de me présenter aujourd'hui devant
vous donc je suis valérie bain j'habite
à villepreux depuis plus de vingt ans où
nous avons élevé nos trois enfants
j'ai un diplôme de docteur en pharmacie
je suis diplômé d'une grande école de
commerce j'ai travaillé pendant plus de
20 ans dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
et puis depuis quelques années je dirige
est un ehpad dans la fonction publique
hospitalière
donc je sais à la fois travailler dans
l'univers du privé et dans l'univers du
public je vais juste faire un petit
rappel sur ce qui s'est passé avant
l'été mois avant l'été nous nous sommes
hantés agir avec vous contre le projet
d'urbanisation à outrance qui nous était
proposé par la majorité municipale
nous avions une préfiguration dise en
face de nous composé de madame ce vin de
monsieur à monique et de monsieur
mirambeau qui briguait un troisième
mandat
après l'épisode de l'été nous voici
arrivés avec cinq listes aujourd'hui
alors nous agir avec vous votre fidèle à
notre projet nous sommes du coup une
nouvelle équipe avec un nouveau regard
pour la ville et finalement c'est une
chance pour les villes provient parce
qu'effectivement nous faisons bouger les
lignes
et du coup nous sommes leaders dans la
réflexion puisque certaines de nos
propositions sont maintenant reprise par
les listes concurrentes
on peut juste s'étonner qu'il faille
attendre un troisième mandat pour que
cela puisse arriver voilà d'autant plus
que nous du coup sans mandat sans réseau
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer
aujourd'hui que nous avons monté un
projet autour de la culture qui est si
cohérent que le directeur du théâtre de
fontenay le fleury monsieur jean daniel
laval a proposé d'être notre mentor dans
la cadre de la mise en place de ce
projet autour du théâtre de villepreux
voilà pourquoi je pense que un nouveau
regard est intéressant pour les villes
troisième voilà pour ce premier tour de
table nous allons aborder un maximum de
thématiques on va essayer de le temps
qui nous est imparti on va commencer
tout de suite avec la question des
finances nous allons débuter avec vous
s'il vit dans mon tel puisque vous avez
un petit peu plus de temps de retard un
peu moins de parler pendant la
présentation la question des finances
sujet forcément important premier des
sujets des engagements de l'état
disparition de la taxe d'habitation font
qu'aujourd'hui plus que jamais les
communes doivent faire attention à leurs
dépenses
sylvie sauveront telles quelles sont vos
propositions sur la thématique des
finances vous souhaitez tout d'abord
c'est ce que vous avez annoncé aux
électeurs réunis régulièrement les
agents pour présenter la feuille de
route et le budget municipal afin de
rester dans les clous aussi oui tout à
fait alors c'est vrai que les finances
c'est le sujet central pour nous c'est
peut-être moins glamour tout le reste
que de parler théâtre espéra mais c'est
le sujet central
on ne peut pas parler de projet sont
de finance de prévisionnel et d'une
gestion responsable
je vais revenir un petit temps un petit
retour en arrière en 2008 quand on est
arrivé on avait une commune qui était
très très très surendettés entre 2008 et
maintenant elle a été considérablement
désendetter en plusieurs millions on le
doit voir ce qu'il ya un adjoint au
maire qu'on attend 2008 qui s'appelle
s'irrite ricard et c'est vrai qu'il a
contribué plus que largement à pouvoir
désendetter la ville renégocier les
emprunts
il ya tout un travail comme ça qui est
capital notamment sa fais pas ça fait
moins rêver que de parler de projets de
théâtre ou de piscine ou de ceux
d'autres choses mais c'est un sujet
extrêmement centrale notre objectif
c'est de bien évidemment maîtriser la
fiscalité on va continuer ce qu'on
faisait de ce qu'on a fait depuis 2008
de maîtriser la fiscalité de maîtriser
les finances de la commune
parce que c'est vrai et ça a été dit
tout à l'heure on a on est quand même
très malmené par l'état il faut quand
même le dire on a des gros sujets
d'inquiétude extrêmement important avec
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
elle va être a priori compenser
malheureux
on a admis là pour déshabiller l'autre
on parle de taxe foncière qui va être
enlevée au départ tu sais comme très
confus tout ça extrêmement confus donc
on peut être très très inquiet de ce
côté là d'où l'intérêt est vraiment
l'élément extrêmement important d'avoir
un projet qui soit réalisable finançable
mais c'est pas que des mots c'est de la
réalité c'est que quand on parle du
théâtre bien évidemment moi je suis ravi
de reprendre ma liberté parce que
c'était suffisamment douloureux à
l'époque on en 1010 de pouvoir le rpt et
ouvrir et lui redonner une nouvelle vie
mais ça sera pas avec une somme à six
chiffres
il faut être extrêmement raisonnable là
dessus pour le dire je peux vous dire
j'ai déjà des contacts avec des
producteurs et c'est qu'on puisse
vraiment faire quelque chose sans du
tout impacté sur le budget de la ville
de façon globale on va aussi bien
évidemment être très responsable sur le
fonctionnement qui va falloir optimiser
les coûts de fonctionnement
c'est évident on est dans une période où
on va continuer ce qu'on faisait depuis
2008 donc il s'agit pas de réemprunter a
attiré la tour de bras pas question de
haut niveau des rh d'augmenter ça c'est
juste plus possible il faut que les
méthodes soient raisonnables qu'elle
soit responsable
on va bien évidemment que c'est que j'ai
reçu le label génération terra faire un
budget participatif je l'ait reçue fin
octobre 2019
donc ça en fait partie on va le
convaincre et on va pouvoir dégager un
peu là dessus parce que ça permet aussi
de donner un peu la parole aux projets
des villes prose ya donc donc ce point
et je vais m'arrêter là vous preniez pas
trop d'avancé que vous ayez le temps de
vous exprimer sur les autres sujets
course ou golgoht lab
vous êtes plutôt critique sur ce qui a
été fait jusqu'à présent sans plomb des
finances est ce qu'on peut lire dans vos
différentes déclarations jusqu'à présent
alors comme un homme politique il croit
jamais en ce qu'il dit il est toujours
étonné quand on le croit sur parole ce
que cherchent ils étaient dix à
villepreux monsieur monsieur le maire
depuis 2008 il présente le taux de
taxation le plus élevé de toutes les
villes aux alentours
chez les diagrammes attendez je vous ai
laissé parler de vous pouvez par taxe
d'habitation en rouge
vous avez dit commune bien sûr on est le
plus élevé messieurs entre 2010 et 2015
on est on là il fait même plus enlever
quand on va sur registre on regarde
jusqu'à 23 24% alors vous le cacher un
moment donné c'est même un peu flou on
ne voit pas très bien je vous laisserai
par les flics et je vous laisserai
parlez vous rejoignez un petit peu les
mêmes modes de fonctionnement contre ces
municipales je vous en prie vous
desservez plus mauvais sur la ville des
clés vous confirmez
les gens en ont marre sur le foncier non
bâti toujours le rouge ses vitraux
pourquoi parce que les électeurs sous
les fonctionnements bâti pour les taxes
elles sont six ou sept
et vous passez pas lourd les gens c'est
avec sa madame qu'ils financent les
projets de la ville
vous me dites que les dotations de
fonctionnement ont baissé bien sûr parce
qu'on a plus de commerces on est la
dernière ville que saint quentin en
yvelines au niveau de subvention de 50
ans l'église pourquoi monsieur tous les
commerces du village
alors vous dites le village ça n'existe
pas je vous rappelle monsieur que la
vieille ville on l'appelle le village
quel est le nom de la ville est-ce que
l'origine du nom de la ville qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire villepreux
c'était des pommiers et poiriers je
crois des fois ça c'était servait alors
le problème c'est que la meilleure force
d'un en politique c'est la culture pour
ce que vous connaissez même pas vous
êtes 12 ans au pouvoir je suis désolé
alors vivre heureux il a été cité cette
ville millénaire villepreux
ça veut dire le village pire c'est c'est
le nom de la ville quand vous me dites
que le village n'existe pas 70% qui vous
a dit ça
vous avez mis sur un post crise où tout
le monde l'a vu je vous dit que pour ce
qu'elle voit là il parle de village 70%
et viril avizois sa vie la naissance à
villers histoire de la ville est
agricole quand on dit rural c'est
l'adjectif pour dire à la campagne dont
votre projet dans votre dans votre étude
enquête publique
il parle d'une ville à la campagne
rurales se disent campagne dernière
chose sur les quais sur les finances
soient compte voilà le désendettement de
la ville
comment comment vous fonctionnez au
moment où madame valadon il arrive
effectivement la ville risque d'être
sous tutelle les comptes se redresse un
petit peu en 2007 2008
vous savez je vous ai cru sur parole
mais quand il ya eu des bisbilles
j'ai dû aller voir creuser et je sais
lire monsieur monsieur le maire à partir
de là je vois que la dette ça reste à
peu près pareil vous avez beaucoup
d'entrées d'argent parce que les taxes
sont très élevés vous avez des
constructions vous avez volé s'est dit
scandalisé conclut et voilà et les
finances diminue au niveau de la tête en
2013 2014 avant les élections
municipales
vous le savez pourquoi parce que bien
sûr le préfet il vous l'a remonté à
monsieur ou monsieur le maire et on va
le forcer
impliqué avec moi stéphane mis en mots
je vous fait forcément répondre si vous
avez été interpellé juste ce qui va être
très compliqué dans ce débat à 5,6 les
quatre tension ça fait lentement la côte
et qu'il y a s'il ya un sujet s'il vous
plaît aussi à votre sujet qui aurait dû
faire consensus comme au niveau de la
gestion de la ville c'est bien la
responsabilité budgétaire qui a été la
mienne elle est citée en exemple par de
nombreux maires aujourd'hui pourquoi
vous êtes en train de dire pourquoi vous
avez de la une taxe d'habitation une
taxe foncière élevé parce qu'on n'a pas
de fiscalité professionnelle sur
monsieur pour on va regarder les
clayes-sous-bois pourquoi on va pas on
va regarder les clayes-sous-bois les
clayes-sous-bois 6 millions 5 de
retombées de fiscalité professionnelle
versée par saint-quentin pour dix sept
mille habitants pour villepreux sait
combien monsieur vous qui avez tout
regarder qu'on vient nous voir
pourquoi on annonce n'est plus à vous
parler sa langue et nos questions six
cent mille euros
cette forme 600 milles 198 600 mille
euros versus 6 millions 5
donc c'est normal que si vous voulez
qu'une ville fonctionne avec tous les
séries pour garoua
laissez moi parler s'il voulait avec
toute chose en paix avec tous nos sites
vous redresser un tout petit peu pour ne
pas cacher la caméra stéphane bien si
vous voulez que villepreux fonctionne
avec tous les services que vous aimez il
faut bien évidemment qu'il y ait de
l'argent pour pouvoir les mettre en
place quand on a un secteur de 10 ce
n'est plus possible aujourd'hui avec
notamment s'exprimer sur le sujet oui
mais si vous passez la parole vous
inquiétez pas interpeller ses
admirateurs voilà extrêmement complexe a
perdu si vous souhaitez changer ma
position aussi en moi je vais donc
dirais juste parce que là je suis
attaqué sur les finances choses
extraordinaires choix que personne ne
m'a jamais attaqué sur sa ville de
villepreux 12 ans c'est quoi ces deux
ces deux millions de dotations issus de
l'état en moins c'est un million de
prélèvements en plus et c'est par contre
si 65% de désendettement 17 millions
d'autofinancement que nous avons pu
mettre en place pour financer nos
projets sans aucun emprunt est une
épargne nette positive sa fille est
repassée qui est repassé positif dès mon
arrivée il n'y a pas d'accusé
mentation la fiscalité il n'y a pas eu
encore une augmentation mais au delà
musiciens aussi c'est pour ça monsieur
singer ici là je sais qu'ils font que
donc si ces voix là non mais laissez ça
va être pas rock et faire vos
propositions être compliqué monsieur
parce que si c'est ça moi je réponds à
tous quand je suis attaqué de manière
extrêmement dur parce que là c'était
extrêmement dur et dont je réponds je
pourrais faire en gros j'ai uniquement
de défendre la tradition vos différentes
propositions vous avez sur la question
des finances proposait notamment la mise
en place d'un comité 0 débauche inutile
on va encore plus loin on a optimisé de
toute façon les dépenses depuis 12 ans
maintenant et c'est pour cela que malgré
les mauvaises nouvelles sommes encore en
vie et nous sommes une commune libre qui
n'est pas sous tutelle de la préfecture
on peut encore aller plus loin mais ne
rêvons pas toutes les économies
énormément ont été faites et si vous
avez des personnes qui ne veulent même
plus que la ville se développe
expliquez-moi comment vous allez pouvoir
trouver encore les centaines de milliers
d'euros pour compenser les baisses de
l'état qui se continue et monsieur à
monique elle se continue peut-être elle
se ralentisse peut-être à l'échelle de
la france mais elle continue à l'échelle
devine que je peux vous en assurez jeu
pauvres dans la lutte notamment par le
pk par le mécanisme de péréquation et
madame rétablir la république en marche
dont vous devriez bien connaître le
sujet jean baptiste à monique vous avez
la parole vous écoutons sur la question
des films alors on va parler des
finances en laisse et de recentrer le
débat en tout cas votre alliance
monsieur gobeil monsieur rambo semble
bien lointaine sa façon dont vous avez
la vieille jour possibilité de 12 ans
colisée
m ne venez pas nous reprocher de ne pas
attention de parler du fond et de voler
comme édition de cibler des gens les
autres me le signaler mentionnons la
moitié soit concentrée sur les villans
avaient juste terminée je rappelle juste
les règles tout le monde a accepté de
venir et merci encore une fois à vous 5
le but est de présenter pour les
électeurs les électrices vos
propositions
donc si vous vous interpeller les uns et
les autres forcément y avait vraiment un
temps pour parler du fond et l'émission
pourra pas être allongée nous devons
nous arrêter de toute façon jean
baptiste amonix étape de façon très
concrète déjà nous nous engageons avec
les villes pourrait naturellement et je
m'engage à titre personnel si je suis
élu maire à ne pas augmenter la
fiscalité locale je n'augmenterai pas
les impôts des villes prises hier ça
c'est une première chose personne
l'accord d'ici je le dis
ensuite vous dire que moi quand j'arrive
quelque part j'aime bien savoir où je
mets les pieds donc même si je suis
d'accord
la situation a été à saigner après un
mandat communiste incarnée par madame
valadon dont certains sont d'ailleurs
sur votre liste madame barre mais je
souhaite qu'on ait un audit
je souhaite qu'on a un audit financier
qui sera réalisé par la chambre
régionale des comptes
dès notre arrivée parce que nous avons
besoin de savoir exactement où nous
mettons les pieds
je suis désolé mais quand un maire est
également adjoint aux finances c'est pas
normal
on n'a pas eu toute la transparence
nécessaire sur les finances même si je
le reconnais messieurs mirambeau et je
vous reconnais je les dis en début de
débat que les finances ont été assignés
bon maintenant quand je disais tout à
l'heure aussi en introduction qu'on
était au bout d'un système au bout d'un
schéma c'est que le schéma était le
suivant c'était de dire on a des bijoux
de famille
on les vend on densifie à une période où
je suis d'accord la ville avait besoin
d'évoluer et la ville avait besoin
d'avoir des nouveaux logements avaient
besoin de répondre aussi à des attentes
et à des besoins locaux donc on avait
besoin de créer des nouveaux équipements
et donc de dégager de l'excédent pour
pouvoir réaliser ces investissements
sauf que le schéma c'était de dire on
densifie on construit on fait de
l'expansion urbaine avec ce que ça a
comme conséquence sur l'environnement et
on obtenait des recettes fiscales comme
ceux comme cela bon je pense qu'on est
arrivé au terme de ce schéma là
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait un second
souffle et ce second souffle c'est de
dégâts c'est de trouver de nouvelles
possibilités de financement vous avez
parlé de la taxe d'habitation je suis
d'accord la taxe d'habitation avec
compensé par la part foncière de la taxe
foncière départementale
après il y aura une réforme de la
fiscalité locale également en 2023 c'est
quoi les faits les pistes de financement
aujourd'hui que qu'on peut dégager
déjà une seconde web l'a un peu dit sur
le commerce de proximité
quand vous dites qu'on n'a pas de
recette liée à la taxe professionnelle
c'est pas une fatalité
je suis d'accord je ne souhaite pas que
villepreux deviennent des
clayes-sous-bois je ne souhaite pas que
villepreux deviennent plaisir en terme
d'aménagement en termes de vie
économique mais une vie économique
locale de proximité
on pourrait la développer on pourrait
avoir des mécanismes un peu plus
d'incitatifs pour faire venir le
commerce c'est eux
j'ai progressé suite des choses qui
fonctionnent le messie le patrimoine
communal
le patrimoine communal plutôt que de
construire à chaque fois que vous avez
une idée vous avez un équipement
regarder ce qu'on a dans le giron
communal on a aujourd'hui des salles
municipales on a aujourd'hui des
équipements publics qui ne sont pas
valorisées moi je préfère rénové
requalifier certains équipements pour
justement financer de nouveaux de
nouveaux équipements qui serviront aux
villes plaisir plutôt tout de suite ce
qui reconnaît monique qu'est ce que j'ai
construit donnez moi en fait un exemple
de ce que vous venez de normes et ce que
je venais de dire vous venez de dire que
je compte je construisais au lieu de
réhabiliter donnez moi en fait un
exemple cher monsieur ce qu'est ce que
vous avez réhabiliter mais vous me dites
que je construis au lieu de réhabiliter
ces deux noms d'autres termes vous avez
en faire un exemple pour les jeunes
j'ai réussi j'ai réalisé c'est à dire
que le quartier des aux usa construit
c'est la crèche
non mais le quartier des rues du moulin
évidemment vous avez quand même donné
votre accord pour qu'on avait une
expansion mais réhabilitation de tuteur
mais non mais justement c'est ce que je
vous dis donc vous allez que je milite
l'existant au lieu de construire un
nouveau quartier attendait ce que je
suis en train de dire c'est que votre
façon fonctionner qui a marché pendant
12 ans parce que la ville avait besoin
d'évoluer se développer ce n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de toute façon n'a plus de
foncier ce qui veut dire que si on doit
et je suis d'accord
une ville est en constante évolution si
on a besoin aujourd'hui de créer des
nouveaux équipements vont ne meurent pas
le faire aucun aucun exemple monsieur un
manic donnez-vous à l'époque où c'est à
vous avez forcément le plus de retard
vous avez écouté jusqu'à présent les uns
les autres discuté on aimerait entendre
vos propositions sur les finances nous
quand on analyse la façon dont est gérée
la ville on a une autre façon une autre
stratégie financière a proposé c'est à
dire qu'elle soit toujours aussi
rigoureuse puisque vous avez été
rigoureux dans votre méthodologie mais
plus équitable vis-à-vis de tout où les
villes provient et sur toutes les
générations
par exemple parce que finalement tous
ces projets d'urbanisation et nous
l'avons mis dans notre programme c'est
que depuis l'année 2016 ou finale
nous avons tous ces logements nous avons
aussi une diminution notre capacité
d'autofinancement donc là nous sommes
arrivés à moins de 500 mille euros
d'autofinancement pour une ville de 10 à
13 milles habitants à la fin de l'année
c'est quand même relativement peu nous
avons peu de marge de manoeuvre
alors effectivement il ya eu beaucoup de
foncier de deux vendus et ça a contribué
à la diminution de la dette
donc en fait on a vendu du foncier ces
pauvres diables quelques élèves ont su
que je voulais cette année je vous ai je
vais essayer les services techniques ont
été vendus et puis et puis nous avons
aussi du coup maintenant les bulles du
trianon qui ont été vendus donc l'enfer
pour un total de 2 8 millions d'euros
c'est quand même assez conséquent donc
effectivement la réduction de la dette
elle s'est fait au dépend en fait du
foncier et du coup nous prive de
solutions pour le futur alors que
finalement il ya d'autres façons
d'aborder des financements et je ne
crois pas effectivement au regard de ce
graphe là que la densification urbaine
que vous nous avez proposé soit la
panacée pour assurer la promotion
elle nous a sauvés sur villepreux
combien a permis de rentrer dans les
caisses de la ville le quartier des eaux
du moulin face une haie de vue vous
allez regarder les chiffres
vous avez tout faux les chiffres non je
ne veux pas que vous donniez les
chiffres moi je vais vous donner les
miens en fait ce que nous reprochons en
fait à votre gestion c'est que tout a
été orientée sur le budget
d'investissement
ça veut dire que le budget de
fonctionnement a servi à alimenter le
budget de fonctionnement c'est toujours
le cas le budget de ce dégagement de
tout à fond mais du coup on a créé un
nouveau quartier aux dépens du budget
des voiries obligatoire n'est pas
forcément s'est porté par cinq encaissés
dans la voix l'excellent bascule sur
depuis de nombreuses années d'excédents
bascule sur un investissement
donc ça c'est ça que nous voulons
absolument maintenant rééquilibrer en
redonnant du fait du coût des moyens
pour le fonctionner du quotidien et vous
faites comment on va s'arrêter là sur la
question des dvd financier nous allons
faire l'émission entière nous avons fait
la moitié de l'émission sur la question
des finances déjà je vole annonce
les riverains je vous laisse la parole
vous avez plus de retard on va parler
d'urbanisme et c'est dans la
prolongation du sujet des finances de
toute façon sur la question de
l'urbanisme et j'imagine que les uns et
les autres auront beaucoup à dire
puisqu'il ya plusieurs projets sur
lesquels vous souhaitez aussi revenir
notamment vous souhaitez geler le projet
central park
oui parce que pour nous l'organisme
c'est avant tout en fait un espace un
lieu où on s'épanouit en famille où on
peut laisser nos enfants évoluer dans la
ville de façon sécurisée et leur donner
un peu de liberté
donc du coup ça implique une certaine
conception de la ville que l'on retrouve
finalement dans le quartier de la
bergerie du prieuré ou du trianon
voilà c'est ça aussi qui fait la qualité
de vie de villepreux
donc du coup nous on n'est pas contre
les nouveaux projets immobiliers mais
par contre on veut respecter en fait
c'est cette identité et 7 ce charmant
fêtes de la ville de villepreux donc
voilà ce qu'on a vu en fait sur ces
dernières années c'est quand même des
projets à outrance juste pour les villes
provient on était une ville de 10000
habitants à la fin de l'année on sera
13001 donc c'est quand même quelle était
l'urgence à augmenter la population et
encore je ne compte pas le projet de
central park
ni les bulles qui viennent d'être vendus
pour construire aussi une centaine de
logements
les bulls et pour financer le gymnase
n'est pas parti la parole les uns les
autres
valérie bas sur cette question de
l'urbanisme pardon sans claire
opposition a présenté à l'est dit oui
mais justement c'est d'abord de faire un
stop de voir comment on peut intégrer
toutes ces populations comment on peut
vivre ensemble accès en fait sur le
budget de fonctionnement donc pour la
qualité du midi chacun réhabilité en
fait effectivement les bâtiments publics
qu'ils peuvent l'être damiri
effectivement est un sujet donc il ya
probablement des on peut en faire un
modèle en termes de rénovation
énergétique
et puis du coup voilà entretenir le
patrimoine
sylvie ce vin montel mise à plat totale
pour assurer l'équilibré linguistique
oui tout à fait j'aimerais bien parce
qu'il serait pas mal sur ce débat qu'on
sait qu'on se recentre un petit peu à
mon avis sur les projets qu'on peut
porter son nom revient toujours en
arrière m'avoir du mal à s'en sortir il
faut aller de l'avant et être proactif
sur ce qu'on peut proposer ça c'est
juste mon point de vue personnel sur
l'urbanisme c'est vrai que sur la
centralité
il ya quelques années j'avais alerté à
la fois le maire et les élus qui était
en charge de l'urbanisme qui sont
précieux manistes le reste je les avait
alertés sur le fait qu'ils allaient trop
vite sur la centralité je ne disais pas
qu'il fallait pas quitter rien faire
mais qu'ils allaient trop vite que c'est
un projet qui serait porté sur un mandat
voire sur deux mandats parce que c'est
très structurant sur la ville et qu'il
ne fallait surtout pas déséquilibrer au
niveau urbanistique environnementale
je parle même pas d'un point de vue
financier parce que le projet actuel
n'est pas finançable en fait donc
donc c'est vrai quand mon avis ça a été
trop rapide ça c'était mon point de vue
à l'époque donc bien évidemment il comme
je reprends ma liberté une vote soit que
je fais une mise à plat et qui on
prendra le temps nécessaire avec les
villes rosien d'où mon annonce danse
admettra que fera un référendum citoyen
parce que ça sera important d'avoir
l'avis de tous il provient des gens du
val doyen du village du prieuré de
partout il faut que c'est tellement
structurants qu'il faut avoir la vie de
tout le monde et pas que les gens qui
habitent dans ce coin là je pense que
c'est très important
c'est pas un petit projet ça après deux
très structurant sur la ville sur le
reste c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
projets qui peuvent voir le jour et fait
extrêmement prudent il faut être très
attentif il ya un endroit qui pose pour
nous qui nous pose un souci c'est là
qu'est la poste
je l'avais annoncé dans une vidéo la
poste c'est un réel sujet parce qu'on a
une épée damoclès qu'elle disparaisse je
vais arrêter là retournera compris
contient notre post et contient ce que
ce service public l'art est pour les
deux produits en doute l'intérêt qu'il
va falloir re qualifié cet endroit là
pour redynamiser aussi les commerces qui
sont compatir soit très jolie comme
entrée de ville il va falloir trouver
une solution pour requalifier cet
endroit là pour les commerces soient un
peu de
qualité ils ne sont déjà eux moi n'est
que le cet endroit là soit soit plus
joli
sur le reste des bulles bien évidemment
que heureusement qu'en décembre
on a voté cette vente des bulles sinon
pouvait pas financer l'école peut
imaginer l'école l'école l'école ne
serait pas ouverte en septembre ça c'est
sûr si on agit seul à voter en décembre
donc c'est très important et un niveau
urbanistique la mairie je l' annonce
aujourd'hui parce que certaines le font
dire des choses que je n'ai jamais dit
donc là des choses sont très claires je
n'ai pas de projet avec mon équipe tous
pourris tre sur la mairie je ne mettrai
pas la mairie par terre que les villes
prochaine je sache elle restera là et
les projets se font petit à petit et en
lien aussi avec les gens qui habitent au
tour donc il ne pas de projet dans les
tuyaux au niveau de la mairie saint jean
baptiste à monique sur cette question de
l'urbanisme ensuite ce sera à
coursegoules gaulle avait ensuite à
stéphane mirambeau pour pour ce tour de
table complet et valérie bonjour
donnerait aussi la parole si vous
souhaitez intervenir puisque vous avez
un peu plus de retard jean baptiste à
monique sur l'urbanisme
vous voulez mettre notamment un terme
aux constructions périphériques c'est ça
alors juste parce que l'exemple des
bulles il est assez significatif et vous
venez de le dire on avait besoin et en
aura besoin quoi qu'il arrive de la
vente de ce terrain pour boucler le
financement de l'école en revanche il
n'y avait pas d'urgence à faire voter
cette délibération avant le
renouvellement de mars prochain
il n'y avait pas d'urgence le problème
c'est que maintenant qu'on sait qu'il ya
des nouveaux logements à cet endroit là
disent maintenant oui mais d'accord mais
ça paye très innovant il aurait très
bien entre de toute façon il faut
rassurer les villes pour rien sur ce
projet ce sera la prochaine équipe
municipale de délivrer le permis de
construire moi je trouve que ce projet a
été dénaturée je parle des bulles en
tous genres par rapport à ce qui devait
être fait initialement il devait y avoir
du local soit pour déminer soit pour la
vie la vie associative entrée du local
municipal soit potentiellement pour
faire venir de nouveaux médecins y avait
déjà des relations qui avaient été
prises ou pour implanter de la com du
commerce en rez de chaussée il n'y a
plus rien on est sur du sang course
engagement ce projet là qui va nous
faire qu'il va faire venir de nouveaux
habitants sur villepreux ça va créer
déjà non pas un déséquilibre mais ça
pousse ça nous pousse à revoir
le projet central park où 250 logements
étaient déjà prévus et ça c'était une
phase 1
c'est la phase 1 la phase 2 qui avait
aussi dans l'esprit de certains c'était
après comme madame c'est vraiment elle
l'a dit c'est est potentiellement de
mettre la mairie par terre pour
construire du logement à cet endroit là
moi non plus je le souhaite je ne
m'engage pas sur ça sur le projet
central park
j'ai toujours été très clair pendant la
campagne sur ce sur cette zone là qui
n'est pas attention juste l'espace vert
en face du collège qui est aussi la
pente à l'ange
moi je souhaite sur cet espace là qu'on
prenne le temps de la concertation mais
le temps de la concertation ça veut pas
forcément dire moi je je crois beaucoup
en démocratie de proximité et à la
participation citoyenne mais je crois
pas que ce soit ce référendum qu'ils
puissent gérer ce genre de sujet ce que
je souhaite moi sur cette zone là c'est
qu'on prenne le temps de voir ce qu'on
peut faire et quels sont les réels
besoins
je ne dis pas que cette zone est voulu
rien n'évoluera jamais parce qu'elle
évoluera ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
n'est pas 250 logements dans un premier
temps et qu'on leur offre qu'on arrive à
requalifier la pointe à l'ange et oui
nous souhaitons avoir des futurs
aménagements éco responsable c'est à
dire ne plus empiéter sur les espaces
naturels les terres agricoles les
espaces boisés
c'est pourquoi c'est pour ça que nous
fixerons un objectif de zéro
artificialisation net
op à buc coureuses goalball à vos
propositions voici vous trouverez la
suspension du projet finira si de vivre
avec re pour la qualité de vie pour la
verdure pour les champs avec ma famille
il ya le reste ma famille qui habite là
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on a construit au bord des changes était
installé dans un quartier il fallait le
faire
je suis allé un peu plus loin au bord
des champs de nouveau vous avez
construit je suis allé et là je vais
arriver au clae donc je m'arrête là mais
vous vous achetez moi même je vous ai
bien sûr chercher parce que je suis je
suis engagé pour vip room suis d'accord
doit s'engager dans ce que vous
critiquez
est-ce que vous déléguez j'ai coupé mes
sfn mais en vol est intervenu juste
après vous pouvez répondre cros golgoht
là que j'aimerais vous entendre sur vos
propositions en termes durs ben voilà
donc dire que si vous interpeller l'un
ou l'autre il faudra vous répondre tous
les tous des gens retournent la fin
monsieur à monique monsieur mirambeau
madame chauvin ils ont voté ils étaient
pour le central park avec mes
interventions il on touche tous ils se
sont tous madame pour m'inquiéter au
mois d'octobre j'ai un projet je vais
t'étonner pour ma part je suis très
étonné vous dit la même chose que moi on
met en suspens vous êtes sorti sur la
gazette de saint quentin le 25 octobre
un article en disant le projet est
cohérent c'est parfait je vous le rende
ici en marche c'est faux le second
verdict
une chose est claire si vous parlez tous
en montant dû s'entendre a pas messieurs
gholam s'il vous plaît monsieur
mirambeau s'il vous plaît sinon c'est
simple vous micro sera coupé on vous
entendra plus parce que c'est inaudible
cause d'algues au lab vos propositions
concernant leurs valises
si vous intervenez les uns les autres
ils voudront vous répondre voilà donc le
centre central park d'ailleurs qui pour
ce passionnant central park c'est 4
millions de mètres carrés à new york de
verdure
moi je leur ai appelé votre votre projet
central d'arc voilà donc vous allez
mettre du béton alors vous n'est même
pas compris la philosophie de central
park ont su que j'ai tout ce qu'il faut
pour vous le montrer pour les bulles
vous en avez parlé vous perdez vous vous
mettez avec le consentement avec le vote
grenade sommes sereins avec nos amis qui
l'ont permis il nous fait goûter ce de
laisser-faire l'abstention est de
laisser faire monsieur ils ont descellé
c'est faire une partie du terrain du
collège pour mettre un bâtiment où ça
devant la pépinière que vous allez faire
six mille mètres carrés constructibles
en bâtiment déconnante dans la ville
ça va être le valoir que vous travaillez
ou vous faites vos posts sur internet et
ça dénature la ville alors vous avez
vendu déjà une première fois au conseil
municipal tout va jusqu'à ce tour vous
l'avez vendée un autre promoteur 5,4
millions huit cent cinquante mille euros
aujourd'hui vous le faites à 3 millions
d'euros et deux millions d'euros qui
vont en découler c'est ce que vous avez
utilisé en 2013 pour rembourser la dette
le préfet tout va étudier en ligne vous
les mettez en ligne
bien sûr et quand sur ans quand vous
voulez réajuster le budget en juin 2014
vous sortez de la salle c'est monsieur
sting qui prend la parole et le préfet
vous avez dit mais je sais que c'est le
contrat
n'importe quoi mais qu'est ce qu'on
entend et sainte-foy-la-grande et
hallucinant et halluciné
je vous passe la porte juste un mot
c'est jean baptiste voulait réagir sur
une chose juste une sanction marque ce
que j'ai dit c'est que le projet tel
qu'il était ne me convenait pas mais
qu'il y avait des choses qui allaient
dans le bon sens ce qui va dans le bon
sens c'est de résoudre c'est d'avoir une
réflexion sur la zone pour prévoir de
nouveaux équipements
moi quand drones au projetj défend un
écran un espace collaboratif parce que
vous ne réglerez service public c'est
parce que vous avez rien que ça résonne
de la pointe allonge ses fans mirambeau
c'est à vous et c'est ça va tout lors de
son être compliqué je pense pendant une
heure ce qu'il ya de plus impressionnant
messieurs à monique vous venez de dire
en introduction vous aviez s'est ténu
avec vous c'était cet élu comporter
centrale par qu'ils étaient en face de
moi
lors des réunions publiques ailleurs
stéphane vous tu as été extrêmement fort
et là maintenant une fois qu'il passe
avec un couteau si les ai dû creuser
bien sûr mais on est aussi délicieux
repas ils l'ont pas fait pendant plus de
deux ans après ce moment elle a duré la
concertation quelle est votre position
ou nationaux
je suis ironique je vais me en vostf à
mirambeau j'aimerais vous entendre sur
vos propositions concernant l'urbanisme
sur les projets qui ont été lancés vous
êtes aussi le maire sortant vous devez
aussi se présenter et échanger sur notre
bilan extrêmement alors allez sur l'aube
absurde urbanisation c'est toujours
extrêmement drôle que c'est toujours le
sujet qui fait peur le sujet on parle de
ça si on veut on veut bloquer le maire
sortant et pourtant vitreux s'est
construit sur l'urbanisation
il suffit de regarder l'histoire de
cette ville le vix le village et les
différents quartiers qui se sont mis en
place après les uns et les autres
vous citez les quartiers de la ville qui
aujourd'hui remettrait en cause la
légitimité du trianon personne parce que
ça fait partie de cette ville et
pourtant en 95 la campagne des élections
municipales a fait perdre monsieur
roulant justement à cause de ça et
maintenant plus de 20 ans après ça fait
partie de la ville vous me dites il ya
trop de logements sur villepreux elle
est où la jauge c'est la jauge des
années 1900 des années 1950 ou des
années 2000 moi je ne sais pas c'est pas
c'est pas l'organisation qui fait peur
c'est la façon dont les maires l'ont
mise en oeuvre et je dois dire que de
l'ensemble des maires qui se sont
succédé depuis les années 1920 c'est
plutôt pas mal non c'est une ville
agréable c'est une ville où on se sent
bien ces mêmes musulmans monsieur
golgoht lab
vous critiquez d'urbaniser
si vous avez acheté deux fois dans le
piano et dans les eaux du moulleau et
vous venez de dire maintenant qu'il faut
que rien ne bouge
mais vous pensez que l'organisation il
suffit de dire je suis content je suis
content je suis content mais de toute
façon il ya une pression de l'état mais
vous pensez que vous allez bloquer tous
les propriétaires qui veulent vendre le
central park
c'est un terrain majoritairement privé
on a trouvé un artifice pour bloquer
tout projet d'extension
s'il n'était pas vu dans son ensemble
vous pensez que c'est le propriétaire
aujourd'hui si je le projet il est utile
c'est un beau projet c'est un beau
projet mais est-ce que vos distances
1000 euros dix neuf mille mètres carrés
de parc
c'est plus qu'aujourd'hui un pôle de
services publics les nouveaux saints non
les français l'ont bien dit lors du
grand débat on venait services publics
profitons justement l'urbanisation
faisant faisons que c'est fort c'est une
proposition que j'avais appris le sait
quand très bien vous allez me dire
monsieur mais robben femme monique
excusez moi
valérie vous avez plus de deux minutes
de retard si vous souhaitez vous
exprimer sur cette question de
l'urbanisme à nouveau si nous ne
passerons un autre sujet écoutez moi je
m'amuse parce que la liste agir avec
vous ses montées contre le projet
d'urbanisation à outrance et
effectivement je me rappelle tout le
monde était favorable
enthousiaste par rapport à ce projet
génial je suis effectivement quand on
vous dit que les projets bouge avec avec
cette dynamique de campagne
là on est en plein dedans quand on fait
donc ses voilà donc oui voilà
effectivement mais ceci dit nous on
reste 6 cohérent avec notre projet on
n'est pas contre des projets de
développement mais quand on est contre
un projet d'urbanisation à outrance dont
on n'arrive pas à percevoir le sens ni
encore du point de vue financier avoir
en fait quels sont les avantages pour
les troisièmes jeux voilà c'est juste ça
en fait
donc nous on reste effectivement attaché
à une qualité de vie à grossir au rythme
naturel en fonction des objectifs du
sdrif en respectant les objectifs dudit
drif mais on n'a pas besoin de faire
trois fois ce que montre le sdrif si on
peut afficher les temps de parole que
les uns et les autres puissent les
constater c'est fmi en beau jean
baptiste à monique
quasiment à égalité 6-6 beaumont tél et
surtout valérie 20 avait plus de retard
et un courant ce goal com à 127,6 vie
sauve en montel sûr on va passer à la
question de la sécurité à présent
quelles sont vos propositions vous avez
été en charge de sur ce mandat de la
sécurité aussi en tant qu'adjointe au
maire
quelles sont vos propositions si vous
êtes élu maire des propositions j'en
aurai forcément c'est un nom qui sera
dans la continuité de ce que j'ai fait
pendant cinq ans et demi puisque je n'ai
plus la sécurité depuis le mois de
juillet je ne l'avais tout s'est arrêté
deux jours langue donc tous les projets
se sont arrêtés de jour au lendemain et
c'est vrai que tout tout ce qui est
référent citoyens j'avais mis ça en
place avec beaucoup d'énergie depuis
déjà un an ça fait un an qu'ils avaient
vu le jour
donc je les déploierez je continuerai à
les développer parce que ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien je continuerai bien sûr
à professionnaliser un peu plus la
police municipale qui a vraiment besoin
qu'on s'occupe d'elle qu'on n'augmente
aussi le la qualité de leur travail au
niveau du matériel
même si on a fait beaucoup depuis 2014
certainement
mon objectif c'est de passer à six
policiers municipaux
donc ça c'est pas du sbpc on va pas
reprendre des asvp ça c'est certain
parce que leur rôle est malheureusement
pas assez en adéquation avec avec des
policiers municipaux il peut même pas
aller dans les voitures de police voyez
ce que je veux dire les svp on
n'entendra pas et par contre si
policiers municipaux minimum on
continuera il ya un point très important
parce que la securitate il pr on y est
plutôt tranquille faut qu'elle le reste
ça c'est ce que j'ai 2014 faut qu'elle
reste tranquille pour ça il faut
travailler il faut travailler toute la
semaine et avec proximité avec les
limites provient donc on a une police de
proximité il faut qu'elle continue sur
cette voie là on a des soucis quelques
soucis de sécurité routière faut pas se
mentir
donc on a des jumelles on a des agents
qui sont extrêmement présents sur le
terrain et qui sont le moins possible
dans les bureaux l'objectif c'est qu'ils
soient dehors ça ans j'ai vraiment
réussi ça j'en suis très heureuse quand
ils seront aussi c'est pour en faire
encore plus mais c'est vrai que cette
proximité là et la proximité de l'élu
pendant cinq ans et demi les villes
projets avènement 06 je peux vous
garantir qu'il m'appelait qu'une suite
dès qu'ils avaient un problème dont
j'étais une énigme extrêmement de
terrain comme
je suis sur d'autres sujets depuis douze
ans et ça peut pas continuer à être sur
le terrain avec eux et avec la zone
sinistrée pour les écouter beaucoup de
voisinage et la sécurité routière je
reviens dessus
c'est un vrai sujet il y en a deux
départementales qui sont très
accidentogène la d11 et là des 98
j'avais à l'époque ça fait deux ans
malheureusement on n'avait ni un
accident mortel
j'avais alerté le département et j'avais
enfin obtenu au printemps dernier après
tout s'est arrêté je sais qu'il ya pas
eu deux là vont reprendre le dossier
c'est que le préfet avait accepté d'un
conte et un radar mobile
donc j'étais très très fier d'être monté
au créneau là dessus parce que c'est
important de pouvoir sécuriser ces deux
départementales là et puis je
m'arrêterai là après je reprendrai aussi
le dossier où j'étais monté au créneau
auprès du gouvernement ne se macron
monsieur castaner et monsieur edouard
philippe pour la police municipale pour
les recrutements
c'est un réel sujet que les huîtres ne
peuvent pas savoir et l'asthme avait
pris beaucoup de temps il faut agir pour
qu'on ait une vraie paix m
et qu'on puisse crantée pour avoir des
agents et qui reste ce sont les agents
ne restent pas ça c'est un vrai sujet
donc je reprendrai tous ces dossiers là
toutes ces dossiers en main et ben vous
écoute à présent parmi vos différentes
propositions réactiver les comités
locaux de surveillance et de prévention
de la délinquance ou encore un travail
en synergie avec la police nationale et
la police municipale des clés alors du
coup je ne pense pas que d'un problème
de qualité sur la police municipale mais
effectivement il ya un problème
d'effectif pour pouvoir couvrir des
plages horaires qui conviendrait plus
aux attentes des villes provient donc
dans ce cadre là effectivement on ne
peut que aller dans le sens des attentes
des villes pro bien puisque la sécurité
est au coeur des enjeux de cette
campagne municipale
après en terme de sécurité on parle
aussi de d'aménager en fait des on parle
de circulation douce mais il faut du
coup pensé avec les associations et puis
les personnes compétentes les
professionnels et experts en fait une
moyen de mettre en place cette
circulation douce on peut donc faire de
la prévention
nous on souhaite aussi pour toujours
accompagné cette sécurité
il n'ya plus en fait d'ateliers
d'entretien de vélo en fait on nous
envoie des gens qui roulent sans lumière
qui roulent sans frein et donc là aussi
c'est quelque chose que konyves et d'une
ici pas lité on doit pouvoir encourager
et essayer de changer les pratiques et
d'éduquer sur la sécurité il n'y a pas
vraiment beaucoup de on a déjà 35
caméras
voilà on est déjà bien équipée de ce
côté-là aussi puissamment elle en est
très importante et que j'en rajouterai à
toutes les entrées de ville parce que
c'était déjà prévu avant et je
continuerai ça bien sûr coureuses
goalball absent aux différentes
propositions concernant la sécurité
j'ai noté brigade canine que vous
souhaitez mettre en place une police
municipale monte aussi et renforcer la
police municipale avec deux harrigan
câline police municipale monter la
police municipale est d'abord préventif
il faut qu'elle soit visible uniforme
c'est l'uniforme qu'ils respectaient les
visible de loin dans toutes les villes
ne souriez pas besoin de cela mais
surtout nous sommes tous les villes qui
ont émis en place ni ont mis en place la
police municipale monter car je la
connaisse aller voir l'article du
parisien ça marche très très bien
maurepas elancourt plaisir mais bientôt
ils mettent tous en place la police
montrent combien vous de savoir combien
ça coûte je peux vous le donne et venez
d'en masse réunion publique ce qui
voulait dire ainsi qu'aux cellules vous
avez été un des principaux un des
principaux merad ou une des principales
maire-adjointe d'abord à la culture deux
heures deux ans la culture anéantie et
plus rien c'est un des piliers de sa
visite après le diabète et à la 2011
après déplorer à magna pourrait alors
excusez moi juste monsieur benoît cyr
les bolbécais bonnes propositions sur la
sécurité la sécurité passe par les
cultures vivaces comparer c'est bien le
but de toujours vivre eux c'est tout
c'est les chiffres monsieur voulait pas
qu'on en parle je les mets sur le site
tout simplement du hip hop en effacer
tout ce projet né mais le projet police
municipale montée avec un effectif
effectivement de deux policiers de plus
c'est une police préventive cm5 voit la
police préventive s'époumoner dire le
policier voit la police préventive
et également une brigade canine le coût
de cette la mise en place de cette
structure pour nos chevaux on a fait on
a étudié les questions ces vingt mille
euros pour l'entretien et pour les deux
chevaux l'achat des chevaux se fait dix
mille euros
il faut avoir les deux policiers toute
manière les deux polices il faut les
recruter à la garde républicaine parce
que il est large mais aussi madame mais
tu sais la même chose tout madame devant
vous devez en voulait embaucher vous
avez écrit à monsieur mac rondeurs pour
avoir sali c'était pas pour ses écrits
du tout goûté ces policiers ils vont
tout toute manière il reste homme les
policiers ne reste pas sur la ville
parce que ils le vivent mal j'ai discuté
avec eux parce qu'elle vous les prenez
deux autres jus pour mettez à parler
notre dirigeant municipal dans un délai
conditions il doit se retrouver dans une
petite pièce à la maison de foot mais
c'est 200 heures de vol à 25 secondes
sans la sécurité la sécurité la vidéo
protection des dizaines de milliers
d'euros je pense que c'est ça suffit
c'est pas efficace augmenter
l'effectif de deux policiers de
préférence des cavaliers police
municipale menthe et qui apporte la rue
réalité l'autorité et j'interviens voilà
c'est maintenant sur la sécurité
qu'elles sont aussi vos propositions à
biao-ci renforcement de la police
municipale gênant surtout regarder cette
série de toute façon pour nous c'est
très clair il faut n'est pas une ville
d'insécurité et les statistiques de la
police mme denat nationale le montre
bien on est la ville de sky où il se
passe le moins de choses on le sait bien
donc il y a eu un gros effort sur la
vidéoprotection il y aura toujours des
actes délictueux sur le territoire il
faut évidemment qu'on mette les moyens
pour lutter contre ça c'est ce qui a été
fait notamment avec la vidéo protection
avec l'armement de la police municipale
et des caméras seront repositionner
tactiquement en fonction des différents
besoins ne déploiera pas encore il ya 35
caméras il est hors de question de
demander plus ce que souffre ce dont
souffrent les villes produit 1 c'est pas
ça moi personne ne me dit monsieur le
maire j'ai peur quand je sors le soir où
j'ai peur de me faire agresser dans la
rue là où on nous interpelle c'est quand
il ya des rassemblements notamment
évidemment de jeunes le soir quand il ya
du bruit quand les gens ne peuvent pas
profiter de leur jardin l'été parce
qu'il ya énormément de bruit il souffre
aussi des incivilités des dégradations
et c'est bien ça le sujet ce sont les
incivilités et les incivilités
on ne résout pas cela en donnant un
numéro de portable de l'adjoint en
charge de la sécurité faut proposer
autre chose faute sur le terrain avec
une force d'intervention locale
c'est notre proposition la brigade
d'intervention de nuit qui sera pilotée
évidemment pas le responsable de la
police municipale qui aura vocation à
intervenir dans les horaires les plus
lus à table écoutez moi ça c'est vous
qui le dites ils vont être très heureuse
d'entendre cela qu'il n'a pas interdit
hier qui vont intervenir sur un principe
extrêmement simple le vide de vie de
produit un soumis à une incivilité
appelle la patrouille est carrément dans
la ville elle intervient en quelques
minutes elle même enfin elle met une fin
assez sensibilité en quelques semaines
n'aura plus d'incivilités de salaire
pour fait la wii et vous allez envoyer
deux personnes reçoivent incivilités 2
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît stop
court aux gold voilà merci plus
intervenir vous avec beaucoup d'avancé
sur les autres nous avons pas pouvoir
respecter l'égalité de traitement de
pendant pendant cette campagne sinon et
ensuite je revois le temps de parole
jean baptiste à monique c'est à vous
excuser moi je vous passe la parole sur
la question de la sécurité rssi alors
sur la sécurité la priorité c'est
effectivement qui est de la présence
humaine sur la commune donc moi je suis
tout à fait en accord avec ça il faut
renforcer les recrutements de la police
municipale c'est pas une mince affaire
il faut voir comment on peut justement
développer des mécanismes incitatifs
pour les faire venir
il faut pas aussi se mentir il ya des
policiers municipaux notamment des
jeunes qui préfèrent aller dans des
communes où excusez moi l'expression
gars de l'action pourquoi parce que
monsieur le maire l'a dit et je le
rejoins sur ce point il n'y a pas de
grosses insécurité à wimereux le sujet
de la sécurité à villepreux c'est les
incivilités du quotidien
hélas il y à une loi la loi engageant
une proximité qui est passé il ya peu de
temps au parlement qui renforce
considérablement les pouvoirs du maire
et donc moi je suis tout à fait tout à
fait disposé à prendre les sanctions et
prendre les arrêtés notamment pour
maîtriser les beats des débits de
boisson pour sanctionner ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles de
stationnement les incivilités du
quotidien on peut les sanctionner on
peut faire on peut faire des choses sur
la vidéo la vidéo protection sur la
vidéoprotection je considère
effectivement que 35 caméras c'est
suffisant il y en aura peut-être
quelques unes à ajouter notamment en
entrée de ville ou dans des endroits où
on a des retours comme quoi il ya
quelques quelques problématiques
ce que je souhaite en revanche c'est
qu'on puisse avoir un bilan de
l'efficacité du dispositif afin de le
moderniser
l'idée d'avoir des caméras nomades je
pense que c'est une bonne solution et
puis et puis dire aussi que si si c'est
tout à fait ici maintenant c'est
possible
et puis oui sur la sécurité la présence
humaine avant tout je ne reviendrai pas
non plus sur l'armement de la police
municipale parce que c'est d'abord
donner la possibilité aux policiers
municipaux se protéger que d'avoir une
arme mais la priorité des villes
prévient ils nous le disent pendant
cette campagne c'est la lutte contre les
incivilités et donc ce serait là ce sera
notre priorité et madame bâ a évoqué le
clspd
moi je souhaite que ce clspd se
transforme en cispd donc qu'il y une
vocation intercommunale pas
intercommunale à l'échelle de l'agglo
mais qu'on puisse travailler en
coopération avec l'ex ou avec les
clayes-sous-bois et plaisir et une
grande partie des candidats seraient
prêts à nous suivre là dessus si on est
aux responsabilités parce que la
délinquance et l'insécurité ne s'arrête
pas aux frontières de villepreux et on a
des zones d'intérêt d'intérêts communaux
vous êtes quasiment tous à 9 minutes 30
de temps de parole nous arrivons à la
fin de cette émission on donc pas le
temps d'aborder à la question de la
démocratie locale comme c'était prévu
j'aimerais que vous ayez le temps de vos
différentes conclusions justes valérie
ben vous avaient le plus de retard je
l'indiquais déjà tout à l'heure vous
avez deux minutes trente de retard sur
les autres avant même de passer aux
conclusions soit vous souhaitez
intervenir sur la sur la sécurité de
nouvelle fois soit vous aurez plus de
temps pour conclure je peux conclure
voilà je vous laisse je vous laisse
conclure pour les autres candidats je le
précise vous aurez une trentaine d'une
trentaine de secondes de conclusion
toute façon l'émission arrive à sa fin
du coup je vais revenir sur l'intérêt
d'avoir de nouveaux visages en fait dans
le cadre de cette campagne municipale
parce qu'on a vu en fait les tensions
donc voila nous aussi on est le garant
d'une main d'une gouvernance apaisée en
fait par rapport à ce que l'on peut
vivre en ce moment nous notre projet il
repose sur quatre piliers en fait donc
la démocratie locale nous n'avons pas pu
parler aujourd'hui
mais vous allez vous inviter les gens à
venir nous
me rejoindre dans nos réunions publiques
l'équité c'est à dire travailler pour
tous les quartiers parce que là il ya
beaucoup de moyens ni sur les eaux du
moulin et villepreux s'il ya
effectivement de nombreux quartiers nous
voulons aussi donc la maîtrise
budgétaire aussi puisque moi
personnellement j'adore les financent
donc c'est quelque chose auquel je suis
très attaché et puis du coup la qualité
de vie par la vie associative la vie
locale le dynamisme du commerce les
associations la culture enfin voilà donc
ça c'est la façon dont nous voulons
travailler je reviens aussi donc puisque
je suis nouvelle dans tour de cette
table pour dire que donc je suis à la
fois en fait directrice d pad donc gérer
des budgets rigoureux je sais ce que
c'est et puis du coup j'ai aussi une
approche en fait social du vivre
ensemble
donc c'est aussi ce que les gens
apprécient en fait dans ma candidature
c'est à la fois cette garantie de
compétence
et puis cette cette vision du vivre
ensemble je profite de l'occasion pour
remercier tous mes colistiers et leurs
familles aussi puisque ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie de s'investir dans
une campagne je remercie aussi tous les
villes provient qui viennent à notre
rencontre qui nous qui nous aide à
réfléchir qu'ils nous apportent des
solutions qui critiquent nos promesses
et qui du coup nous amène aujourd'hui à
proposer un programme donc voici que
nous allons distribuer voilà où nous en
sommes très fiers
nous en sommes très fiers exactement et
donc nous avons des réunions publiques
la prochaine se place samedi 29 à 16
heures à la nex du théâtre nous espérons
vous y voir nombreux
stéphane mirambeau c'est à vous pour la
conclusion en une trentaine de alors une
trentaine de secondes c'est extrêmement
compliqué pour moi parce que vu que
j'étais au centre de beaucoup de
critiques moi je voudrais juste te
revenir
on pourrait penser qu'avec cinq listes
ville de pau est une ville qui
fonctionne mal c'est une ville de
l'inculture c'est une ville de
l'insécurité
moi je voudrais qu'on retienne
simplement ville pose est une belle
ville et c'est pour ça que je pense
j'espère qu'on est tous là pour ça c'est
une visite est préservée c'est une ville
qui recherchait c'est aujourd'hui une
ville verte c'est une ville qu'on
connaît maintenant non plus parce
qu'elle est proche de ikea c'est parce
qu'on a envie de venir il ya des gens
qui veulent venir et qui rêve devenir
survie
les limites prévient quand ils sont là
ne veut plus quitter cette ville moi je
dirais gardons en tête tout le positif
qui a été fait il ya un bilan réel un
bilan fort c'est le bilan de douze
années de ma demande alors on peut aimer
les promesses on peut aimer aimer les
rêves quand je vois c'est vrai que le
programme que je défends il ya moins de
rêve dedans il ya beaucoup de réalisme
et de responsabilités maintenant le
choix et aux villes le président vient
évidemment le set également vous allez
faire un petit peu la faute à une
solution j'en vois les uns les électeurs
les électrices les uns les autres au
site internet des différents candidats
pour avoir la totalité de leurs
programmes et aux réunions publiques
vous avez compris on a encore d'autres
d'ici au premier tour jean baptiste à
mo'nique pour votre conclusion même
chose 36 malheureusement pas eu un débat
mon avis audible pour les présidents
c'est bien dommage
je pense que on aura plein on n'a pas
parlé démocratie locale donc moi je vais
faire ma conclusion là dessus parce que
c'est important
moi je suis pas élu je suis aussi un
nouveau visage dans cette élection
oui non élu non non non non bah oui mais
ce qui montre bien que nous avons
toujours eu des désaccords aussi donc je
suis sur ces moments là que j'ai en tête
la coupe et je n'aurai pas tous parlé de
localiser démocratie démocratie locale
et participative c'est important et
c'est au coeur de notre projet
d'ailleurs nous avons mené une enquête
pendant cette campagne pour prendre le
pouls de la population parce qu'on
considère qu'on peut pas tout savoir
qu'on a besoin aussi d'avoir les retours
des villes président pour construire
notre projet c'est pour ça que c'est un
projet citoyen il a été construit avec
les villes plaisir et le slogan pour la
ville de demain parce que on porte une
nouvelle ambition je les dis il ya des
choses qui ont été faites moitié bien
fait mais on peut pas aujourd'hui
arriver en disant mon projet c'est le
bilan est mon projet c'est la maîtrise
budgétaire
le jeu c'est l'arrêt c'est la rigueur
budgétaire en 10 secondes un budget ce
sont des choix politiques et nous les
choix politiques nous les ferons dans
notre projet ils plairont ils paieront
pas toute promesse sera financé on ne
fait pas des fausses promesses et on a
une ambition qui est d'apaiser
villepreux et de lui donner un second
souffle si les imams ont-elles votre
conclusion en 40 secondes
alors pour terminer je suis donc élu
depuis 12 ans je resterai une élite
proximité ce que je fais depuis 12 ans
je sillonne la ville en permanence
donc je tiens énormément cette proximité
que les villes prose ya apprécié chez
moi qui vont apprécier avec mon équipe
donc je vois là je mobilise un maximum
de vies de croisière au niveau 2 au
niveau de tous les projets bien
évidemment je vais répondre la même
chose
ils sont financés sont responsables le
projet les villes projets auront dix
jours avant le premier tour dans leur
boîte aux lettres et non plus sera
dedans il n'y a pas de de promesses non
tenues à bhl dans notre projet grossman
que la votre conclusion vous aurez 15
secondes maximum maison médicale de
garde ouverte de 8h30 à minuit ouverture
de la culture musées office de tourisme
un grand collège pour les petits parce
que ça arrive à saturation limitation de
l'urbanisation et enfin une boucle elle
est enfin une police sécurité tout est
financé tout et travaillent des
centaines d'heures il n'y a pas beaucoup
de financement parce que ça va être une
maison médicale privée contrairement à
vous qui le république vous me disiez
non au départ maintenant voulait le
faire
tenez l'urbaniste vous avez dit
effectivement elle est allée trop loin
maintenant
voulait le faire il faut être cohérent
monsieur rentre merci adolescents
participer à des missions il assez
d'avoir participé à ce débat
les temps de parole s'affiche une
dernière fois comme j'avais indiqué à
plusieurs fabricants vous avez plus de
retard la campagne se poursuit nous
aurons l'occasion de rééquilibrer tout
ça au cours des différents rendez vous
que vous allez proposer sur la commune
je vous rappelle la date du premier tour
du scrutin le 15 mars d'ici là à bientôt
sur tv 78 radio sensations pour un
nouveau débat
[Musique]